Anyway, where's Susie?
She went to the ladies' room.
Oh, here she comes.
Hi, Kathy! You finally made it!
Hi, Susie! I'm so sorry to keep you guys waiting.
No problem, the traffic always seems to get worse when it's raining.
You're right, but you know what, I like rain.
I think rain makes all things clean in the world, including me.
What a nice day we're having!
Yeah, I like today.
It's cool, isn't it?
The weather forecast says it will be cold tomorrow again.
Really? These days, the weather hasn't been normal for this time of year.
Changmin, what's the weather like in Korea?
Well, it's also autumn in Korea...
...and beautiful around this time of year.
My favorite season is autumn.
I miss Korea.